okay welcome back we're now on problem
number 15 and I tried my best to draw
this graph ahead of time this is
probably one of the more difficult for
me with my with my shaky hand let's see
what this says so this is 0.04 the
origin right here this is point P this
is point Q and of course this is y-axis
this is the x-axis and they say that
this graph right here is y is equal to a
minus x squared and this curve right
here is y is equal to x squared y is
equal to x squared so the the question
says in the figure above the graphs of y
equals x squared and y equals a minus x
squared for some constant a oh those are
the graphs right if the length of PQ is
equal to 6 so PQ is equal to 6 that
length is equal to 6 what is the value
of a well it's interesting if so the
first thing they should jump out at you
is that these are completely symmetric
graphs right they both they both are
kind of mirror images around the y-axis
right so if if this length is 6 then the
length of each of these then here is 3
and then that here is 3 right so what do
we know about where these graphs
intersect well we know that they
intersect at the points at the point 3
and we know that they intersect as well
at the point minus 3 those are where
those two graphs intersect and that's a
lot of information and the way once
again we came to this conclusion was
that these are both symmetric around the
y-axis so if this if this intersection
is 6 wide then it's three on each side
right three of the positives right
through the negative side so it
intersects at x equals 3 and x equals
minus 3 and if we want to figure out the
intersection we can also just set these
two equal to each other y equals x
squared y equals a minus x squared so we
know that
x squared must be equal to a minus of
what am i doing a minus x squared or add
x squared to both sides of this equation
you get 2x squared is equal to a right -
x squared is equal to a and and this
will be true at the two points at the
two X points at where these two graphs
intersect well what what are the Dex
points we figure that out it's three and
minus three right so if you put three in
here you get two times three squared is
equal to a this two times nine is equal
to a a a is equal to 18 and if you put
minus three in here to be the same thing
because when you square it the negative
goes away so a is 18 not too bad
the key conclusion you have to make is
that they intersect at the point
positive and negative three and then you
just set the equations equal to each
other and solve for a alright let's do
the next problem
clear image okay set X has X members and
set Y has y members set Z contains all
the members that are either in X or Y
with the exception of the K common
members okay so this sounds like a Venn
diagram I don't if you remember a Venn
diagram but I will show you what one is
so let's say that this is set X that is
set X and let's make let's say that this
is set Y right here that is said why it
looks like a MasterCard logo so this is
set y
this is set X and it says set Z consists
of all of the members that are either in
set X or set Y with the exception of the
K common members so this is you know
this is kind of the K common members
right these are the the things that
overlap with set X and X well it would
set X and set Y so what does Z consist
of well Z is gonna be Z is gonna be let
me pick a dark color z is gonna be if I
do the fill tool it's gonna be that Plus
that right without the K right because
it says Z does not include the overlap
so what are those two things so let's
see let me go back to a paint tool
orange is gonna be tacky with all the
colors I'm using so there's X members in
all of X right X members you know in all
of capital X so how many members are in
this blue region so if there X in the
whole region there's gonna be X minus K
in this blue region right I just
subtracted out this K part similarly Y
has Y members right as a problem so this
capital y set has Y lowercase Y members
but if we take out these K that overlap
this is gonna be Y minus K I'm just
subtracting it out and so Z is this blue
area plus this blue area so it'll be X
minus K plus y minus K and that is equal
to well it's X plus y we have 2 minus K
so it's minus 2k and that is choice D
not too bad huh all right I think we are
all done with this practice test
hopefully you found it vaguely useful
I'll see you soon